this is from the hill it says caitlyn
jenner is reportedly eyeing a bid for
governor of california
um the former keeping up the kardashians
reality tv star in olympian is talking
with political consultants
as quote she actively explores a run um
and uh apparently what i had read was
that there's someone from the trump team
involved in this actually no surprise
there
you know and and uh of course they they
always make
you've always got all kinds of
interesting people running for governor
in california so that's
that's par for the course but i am
seeing some conservatives
online who are saying this is great you
know i have caitlyn jenner
republican the then
the left's not going to know what to do
you know we we play the left's identity
politics game against them and um
and and they'll be totally disarmed
it doesn't work that way how many times
we have to see it doesn't work that way
in order to play the left's identity
politics game against them to use it
against them effectively
uh they have to have integrity
and live by their own standards which
they don't
so yes it you know when when they've got
rachel levine
as the assistant health secretary and uh
if you
if you criticize rachel levine they're
gonna say you're automatically a
transphobe
it's not gonna work that way you might
you might wish that it would but it
doesn't work that way if the republican
governor of california
is transgender and then you know the
left criticizes
him and then you think you can say well
that makes you a transphobe
they that's their standard it only they
only apply it to us they don't live by
it
no matter how often we complain that
they don't live by they're not going to
and also this you know this gender stuff
gender theory as i have been saying for
years
um even as many conservatives laughed
about it and told me
you're going to die on this hill this
isn't the hill to die on i was told it
was a sideshow i was told it was uh
you know a passing fad it won't matter
as i've been saying for years and have
there's another one of those i hate to
say i told you so situations but
i was correct and am still correct that
this is one of the defining issues of
our time
so we can't embrace left-wing gender
theory in hopes of playing their
identity politics game and using it
against them like it's gonna be some
great chess move it's not gonna work
we lose a lot more than we gain well i
hope you enjoyed that clip for the matt
wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content